Caption: [Applause]
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so today we're going to talk about mice
Caption: and when we get home I'm going to share
Caption: stories
Caption: ladies come out of this room today
Caption: feeling a little bit how to bring your
Caption: unconscious bias into consciousness and
Caption: also
Caption: that's wrong this is me
Caption: and other things that I want to talk
Caption: about here is barri actually pulled
Caption: their biases so between the ages of 0
Caption: instead is when we Bourne Identity
Caption: so things to do means that parents say
Caption: to us whatever you say about others what
Caption: our education says their environment
Caption: dictates shapes
Caption: sir and suddenly the peace around us
Caption: also cultures that we interact with it
Caption: helps pool in those stereotypes
Caption: statements
Caption: from the ages of 17
Caption: we mirror so we then find evidence to
Caption: back up whatever that story might be
Caption: so for me stories around race became a
Caption: really big thing so
Caption: during the 80s and 90s
Caption: efficiently ancient invention now I'm
Caption: born in Australia but I was on the
Caption: receiving end of a lot of that
Caption: sorry what happened was I actually
Caption: internalized all of that racism towards
Caption: myself I thought that I wasn't ready
Caption: that I wasn't belong
Caption: so I'm going to improve connectivity I'm
Caption: some of uniforms or pads or whatever I
Caption: think I'm gonna say a few words for you
Caption: today fill in the blank so for example
Caption: [Music]
Caption: leaders up
Caption: this thing that comes to mind
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: so some of you have might have written
Caption: down some really awesome things just
Caption: right
Caption: so I'll get in touch with anyone so a
Caption: negative belief is some money might be
Caption: that values scarcity I have the belief
Caption: it's not really helpful when I run a
Caption: business
Caption: when you try to accumulate wealth if you
Caption: think that's angle what you do is you
Caption: spend it and get rizzoli as possible
Caption: so the positive
Caption: grace money is abundant
Caption: money is an exchange of energy
Caption: money can be used to support my friends
Caption: and my family myself
Caption: so we might take those beliefs of
Caption: scarcity around my user for me I grew up
Caption: in the low socio-economic space and
Caption: believe that my name is really hard
Caption: really hard to get everybody else had it
Caption:
Caption: and so really hard to shift that belief
Caption: into
Caption: because who would I get to baby
Caption: it wasn't content
Caption: and the same thing goes for when they
Caption: talking about women in tech
Caption: so for me I was going into communication
Caption: select a cell stroke and I was a
Caption: business manager to Telstra pull that
Caption: down
Caption: I'm going to turn down to the I
Caption: engines
Caption: so I just want to flip that
Caption: empowering men
Caption: that I've been a bad thing
Caption: [Music]
Caption: because what I didn't realize was that
Caption: was unconscious
Caption: and she was like whoa what
Caption: was wrong
Caption: sorry
Caption: my own biases we're around
Caption: and I was
Caption: that I won't even be when we just and
Caption: understand
Caption: some of you who know me know that
Caption: suffering from PTSD
Caption: [Music]
Caption: the reason I say those things is there
Caption: one other introverts and other people
Caption: who suffer from PTSD or anxiety to
Caption: realize that doesn't have to be admitted
Caption: to store it
Caption: it doesn't have to be the bias that you
Caption: hold against yourself just stop you from
Caption: taking actions and doing I
Caption: had a fun game of internalized racism
Caption: what would happen growing up is I would
Caption: date an Asian guy and eating his name is
Caption: Jonathan it was terrible but
Caption: my father said to me you
Caption: [Music]
Caption: can't date him he's patient
Caption: my mom was sitting next to him she's
Caption: Chinese
Caption: I'm going
Caption: and he said to me you know sending our
Caption: genetic lineage backwards
Caption: horrifying
Caption: so here I'm thinking
Caption: Asians
Caption: so I admit that I took on board all of
Caption: these believes that comments made was
Caption: less then
Caption: part of me wasn't worthy and
Caption: admittedly it made one hell of a lot
Caption: hotter
Caption: hotter than most people would it meant
Caption: that I would create scenarios where I
Caption: would become the most underestimated
Caption: person in the room
Caption: there is a power in being the most
Caption: underestimated
Caption: because what happens is you get to
Caption: observe
Caption: you get to observe how others treat
Caption: others
Caption: the second thing was so the third thing
Caption: was that I have the last seven years
Caption: told myself I am completely in oil I
Caption: run my own business that's been the
Caption: story of you telling myself oddly enough
Caption: in the interview last week I got head
Caption: hunted for a job through minting kind of
Caption: cool
Caption: not for me best interview I've ever had
Caption: in my life
Caption: who when I get to be if I didn't hold on
Caption: to the story that
Caption: I might
Caption: so all of these different biases play
Caption: out in how we approach life it's not
Caption: just about everybody else's last week
Caption: all have bias in one way shape or form
Caption: because we grow up with a certain
Caption: environment
Caption: so
Caption: now we know each of us
Caption: so physical everybody cut yourself a
Caption: break
Caption: you cannot be held responsible for what
Caption: happens between the ages of 0 & 7 I
Caption: wasn't sure but I was a kid really
Caption: so kind of something bright understand
Caption: that these beliefs will form to the
Caption: environment you have no
Caption: second bringing awareness to your bias
Caption: is
Caption: sometimes true especially when it's
Caption: unconscious it usually takes an event
Caption: [Music]
Caption: but I will bring out our outrage
Caption: and what's important is to stop take a
Caption: break
Caption: and we look at that bias what is that
Caption: is that actually the situation that I'm
Caption: in right now or has it occurred before
Caption: because we met we build evidence over a
Caption: long period of time
Caption: that advice is true disposable
Caption: confirmation bias which is
Caption: we surround ourselves with people with
Caption: like-minded beliefs and
Caption: often don't challenge it
Caption: the great relationships with people
Caption: who will challenge your bias in a good
Caption: way I'm so very lucky that I'm
Caption: surrounded incredible human beings
Caption: Michele is absolutely one of them who I
Caption: will have my own challenges in something
Caption: I'll have a conversation with her and
Caption: when we have that conversation it is in
Caption: a safe space I am never judged and we
Caption: when you're working in your workplaces
Caption: or working with your peers that is the
Caption: importance of safe space
Caption: somebody might have a countering belief
Caption: to you that is challenging you cannot
Caption: fit it in to them
Caption: instead find out what their preferences
Caption: so we often talk about the map is not
Caption: the territory
Caption: so when you look at Google Maps
Caption: it's not the same as being on the corner
Caption: of that street seeing the people who are
Caption: walking around
Caption: so we mapped our childhood every single
Caption: one of us in this room would have a
Caption: completely different that
Caption: when we've built those beliefs and was
Caption: that landmark advice
Caption: and this leads to how we operate
Caption: above the one over whether one
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so about the one is about outcome
Caption: you're just on outcome rather than being
Caption: reactive well either one is way or being
Caption: reactive
Caption: that outrage fatigue that we're all
Caption: feeling at the moment from the Internet
Caption: as a whole
Caption: so when they see somebody who's
Caption: operating below the line
Caption: being able a scheme questions as to what
Caption: limps about
Caption: how did you come to that conclusion what
Caption: is it about this situation you can
Caption: change
Caption: being above the line means that you're
Caption: talking about result so Roy Melanson
Caption: rebellion names down here
Caption: rely on others when we rebelled
Caption: teenagers
Caption: is way living were more reflective and
Caption: responsive
Caption: because you just compensate
Caption: so my best way of managing these kind of
Caption: situations
Caption: take a breath
Caption: what made you feel this bad
Caption: so usually when I will do this very who
Caption: made me feel this way first and
Caption: how is this situation similar
Caption: remind yourself that others don't have
Caption: the same environment
Caption: so about four years ago I lost a partner
Caption: in a motorcycle accident very
Caption: interesting
Caption: in doing that what happened was I was in
Caption: tremendous grief
Caption: very few people
Caption: know how to have a conversation about
Caption: growth and
Caption: that most people feel uncomfortable I
Caption: feel tremendous discomfort
Caption: in breath
Caption: ask two really frustrating questions
Caption: what is how he died and
Caption: the other is despair over
Caption: because I don't know what to say
Caption: so they say that
Caption: and it's taught me a tremendous amount
Caption: of patience with people
Caption: and really
Caption: my hope that you guys leave with this is
Caption: having more patience in understanding
Caption: the intent behind somebody's comments
Caption: that might be biased
Caption: wife the manager who turned me down to
Caption: management because I was too much
Caption: patience and understand where that's
Caption: coming from and we understand and have
Caption: that patience then we can shoot that
Caption: conversation in the right direction so
Caption: I have been trees that reframed a lot of
Caption: my unconscious bias so a lot of my
Caption: managers that the women around the
Caption: abundance
Caption: accepting abundances of myself my family
Caption: my prints and
Caption: having more than enough rather than just
Caption: enough
Caption: finding the right people you can talk to
Caption: you might create that confirmation
Caption: advice
Caption: every single one of you has the
Caption: opportunity to being that person
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thanks so much
Caption: everyone please submit your feedback is
Caption: really important that we give us because
Caption: feedback and also
Caption: [Music]
Caption: thanks again thing as ten minutes until
Caption: the next session so if you need to get a
Caption: puppy right get
Caption: in
Caption: [Applause]